today feels like the first time actually
meeting Lee because although I was here
with him last time Lee wasn't here with
us me neither
morning eyes were popping those things
like that's why I gave him up for Lent
oh you did yeah I gave my full and
there's the second time you leave that
okay if you just got back into it right
yeah but they ain't doing big now no I'm
pretty happy because I load my tolerance
and that'll see BB oil is working better
for me yeah and I got my wife hold on
Ziggy deal which is [ __ ] unbelievable
Scott really is great for you she kept
telling me I'm gonna sleep I'm up at
3:00 in the movies and that's over take
the CB deal so for a week she didn't
take a CB deal I take it to sleeping
like a Zombo you know what she said to
me tonight then I looked at the tank
this THC and I go what the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with you didn't
know that that's why you sleep like a
Zombo CEO she hurt him with THC in it
[ __ ] you that's the only way I do it
because it gets it to the system a lot
yeah I got this stuff they'd get yelling
tears knees like it's no I I do use it
but it's like it's not psychoactive
there's no THC in it this is a
psychoactive but a beautiful smoke okay
you get something Gaga I sucked it to my
god [ __ ] hips okay she can calm
him and she can flame they have took the
pain away but boy I slept there Tina I
was last night and that's what people
want
I put yeah my buddy just got a shoulder
surgery he's taking a lot of - I take it
cuz it's good for like for your brain
stuff like that it's like like shots in
the head sometimes so yeah you know guys
I've been in this know it's good for
brains it's good for circulation it's
just good you sleep better it's good for
muscle pain like yeah I won't take it an
inclination all that because I was
actually getting [ __ ] hungry let's
get back to jiu-jitsu I pop to town
walls I took a gallon of water and I'm
sprayed three of those sprays under my
tongue and a couple weeks ago I almost
didn't make it to the [ __ ] podcast
I'll give you the munchies it gave me
[ __ ] much menu what do you mean you
make it to the park I'll [ __ ] fire I
don't get many a higher than if I [ __ ]
no no because you have to get one for
one that's what it's called this is one
for one there's two for one
then there's no THC okay go on - what a
guy like you has to do no THC because of
the testing like move dick you can do
one for one
before you leave tell me to get you two
bottles or one for one from perennial
the 64 piece and then [ __ ] tremendous
you'll sleep like a baby anyway you'll
sleep like a baby
yep before you take another box you take
the label off maybe I put the cap on it
you put it in the baggie so it doesn't
spill and you put on the inside of your
shaving kit if they look in there I
think that's mother's burden help right
now looking therefore we are looking at
for literally a business if they're
gonna be that creepy right and you and
then and they're gonna take it out and
read it and it's not their world guys so
they're really not gonna bust your balls
then just man I want it all that CB deal
just keep saying CB deal and it's a
[ __ ] scientist comes over and says
this has THC you blame it on this is my
[ __ ] son I told him no THC play the
puppet trick on me that's one of a [ __ ]
I've never - then I'm gonna come back
and totally in jail they might not know
we they're not going to throw you in
jail cuz then you're gonna play stupid -
and what were you talking about
my dad his back hurt so he has [ __ ]
headaches what's the rule number one of
the church you don't know nothing I
don't know nothing happening so he's
gonna blame it on you you're gonna blame
it on him
it's a big misunderstanding you donate
$100 to the Jew Federation of America
for a scholarship to summer camp the
Shabak camp right listen Bob camp what's
the name of it okay how about it Ahmad
Shahbandar telethon I think it's a
Shabbat yeah same difference it do sir
that's awesome but then I don't [ __ ]
say that until you didn't even know what
those guys they really don't it's not
like that train and CB deal
do you think they're really not they
know the cut that was still very blind
to this still they know if they find
that they're gonna ask you what is
missing then CBD or you could spray on
your back
cliff free bro you know many times my
back is hurt like just sore from Walla
jiu-jitsu and they have samples after
we'd store you just take them pull up
your shirt and by the time you walk on
it you have no pain in your back it
feels like you put that freezer on your
back and [ __ ] I you know I'm not a THC
expert uh uh I might be lucky gone
no no hey I'm a [ __ ] idiot compared
to other people but I know how things
make me feel and I know how it affected
my wife my wife don't get high today she
was giggling she says that's got PhD in
it you [ __ ] that's why the other
night I couldn't tell her you watch
thought about nice if you're gonna [ __ ]
you were for like 10 minutes
she goes I didn't know if you [ __ ]
went to sleep she that's how high she's
getting but last couple weeks ago like
this five sprays and I got up at four to
Pete the room was purple it's like that
time I did ecstasy and woke up in the
middle of that I took an x1 went home
fell asleep I got to pee in the middle
like the room was [ __ ] purple